lefties flap their lips about a trump
apocalypse Donald Trump is sending
Democrats into an existential panic over
the very real possibility he could win
the White House again that's not saying
much of course because they're always in
a panic and Whippy Goldberg is here to
say it's ours to lose I'm here to say
it's ours to lose
it is this country either you want it to
work Forward Thinking or you don't or
you want somebody who says I'm going to
be on day one I'm going to be a dictator
who says it to you tells you I'm going
put you people away I'm going to take
all the journalists I'm going take all
the gay folks I'm going to move you all
around and disappear you if that's the
country you want you know who to vote
for you got that whoopy says if Trump
wins he's getting rid of all the
journalists and the
gays there goes half my
staff and we don't have any
[Laughter]
[Applause]
journalists meantime radio host
Charlamagne the God thinks President
Biden has historically been for lack of
a better word a elected official but you
know Donald Trump would be the end of
democracy as we know it I think
President Biden historically has been uh
lack of lack of a better word the
elected official but you know Donald
Trump is the end of democracy as we know
you've heard it so much cuz every time
you know there's a republican candidate
people say oh it's the end of democracy
you know uh you know he's the people say
go so far say oh he's the Antichrist but
this is one of those times where you
know it really actually positively is
true you know but if he's the god he has
no reason to fear the Antichrist I don't
get it but to call Trump the Antichrist
is excessive at least while Dave
Matthews still walks the
Earth
why and former n
MSNBC hack Chris Matthews warns this
election is going to be close it's going
to be very close this election is going
to be close it's going to be very close
in place like Pennsylvania and you're
going to have rural people out there
voting their craziness about the cult so
you better be there to match them and
you got to be their vote against that
and I'm telling you this is really
important that you vote for your rights
the craziness about the Cults okay
Grandpa they're not even hiding their
hatred for you anymore it's out in the
open for all to see just like Hunters
Wang and Obama's closest Confidant say
the former president also fears a close
race on the bright side it's nice to see
Obama afraid of something besides
Michelle
so we're still 10 months away from
election day and the dams have already
pivoted from calling Trump Hitler to the
Antichrist but if this keeps up they're
going to have to call Trump a name
that's even worse like
[Music]
President Tyrus How Will trump get rid
of the gays I mean he had four years to
do it I don't know now we have more gays
been trying for years they just they
keep popping up they're clever they're
clever like that always outsmarting us
yes they
are evil sneaky
gays they're everywhere oh man helping
me dress
appropriately always there when I'm
sad what the hell man you
know the whoopy thing drives me crazy
because she's so protective of these
liberals and all this stuff but this is
the same group that you had to change
your name to get a job mhm you know what
I'm saying that's how they are but yet
he's the bad guy like it's just
important and charman the god proved
he's not God because that's what happens
when you speak your mind when you're
over on the other side and they control
the rights to your TV show you have to
go to the principal's office and he was
talking like my son does when I when
he's in trouble but they the lady said
so were you saying that Biden was bad
and he was like well yeah I said he was
bad but but Trump's way worse he's so
way worse but yeah he's a he's a elected
official and he's ruined the country but
Trump is I'm gonna say it Trump is Trump
is bad he's the Antichrist you the
uncomfortableness yeah because he was on
his radio show but now he's on his got
his TV show and they'll take all that
away so he had to back he had to back
down because he likes his shows so he
had to say that Biden's bad but Trump's
worse but he didn't he wasn't
comfortable saying Trump look at his
body language like that's uncomfortable
he made a choice to where he folded
because he knew he's seen the results of
being cancelled if he went on CNN and he
just stopped at Biden is a bad president
it would be Charmaine the ghost because
we would never see him again MH cat you
know how can like people not see that
they're victims of a hysteria it's like
they could step out and go like okay I'm
being completely idiotic right now he's
not the Antichrist
he's not Hitler what is it about that
well you know what's so interesting is
that Charlamagne called Trump the
Antichrist but he's also been willing
several times to criticize Biden so like
what is literally everybody else's
excuse you play that clip and you show
Charlamagne he's actually one of the
more levelheaded people out there
because if you watch whoopy the view is
a great example have they ever said
anything critical about Biden maybe
maybe I missed it but usually it's this
over-the-top unhinged criticisms of
trump because people view any criticism
of Biden as somehow helping Trump
because this is horrible even and
Charlamagne was right that when you say
that over and over and over again it
really does kind of lose some of its
luster I feel like somebody calling
someone the Antichrist would have in the
past been like a bigger deal whereas
this people like oh they're doing it
again so I think it's a lot of people
have just tuned it out at and actually
more than that a lot of people
are are they don't want to hear any
criticism of trump cuz that people have
already lost their credibility in
criticizing him yeah huge let down Biden
to the American people there was the USA
poll that said people aren't
enthusiastic about voting for Biden the
second time around if you voted for him
in 2020 ah you're not as enthusiastic
yeah well no kidding I mean the only
thing that he's excited about is maybe
going to sleep going to the bathroom uh
so huge let down open borders numerous
Wars across the uh across the world um
and still the economy we had inflation
data this morning I know you love it
when I talk about economy uh the
inflation data confirmed your food costs
are still up your uh your rent is still
Skyhigh and gas gas prices are still off
the charts right now and the American
people know that and so I think the
democrat's biggest bet is not in favor
of Biden it's against Trump yeah and
you're right uh Joe Biden is uh excited
to go to sleep but he's even more
surprised when he wakes
up true very
true so is Dr
Jill Jamie you must sympathize with
Trump often being called names unfairly
MH I do sympathize with that also I
don't think we should attack Biden for
being excited to go to sleep and go to
the bathroom uh I can't wait to do those
things um you know what can I just be
the one to say that whoopy looks like
she was getting a haircut and the power
went
[Laughter]
out it just
it so what I don't get is that they're
like oh if Trump is President is the end
of democracy as we know it but he he was
President yeah and it's not it hasn't
been like that's not true if he was
President everything's fine he could be
president again it's overstate I feel
like I didn't like the ter ology whoop
be used I didn't like how she said that
Trump was going to disappear gay like
who teaches her grammar Tony Soprano
like disappear gay um actually did you
know that disappear gays was the
original name of the Sig freed and Roy
uh Vegas show really
[Applause]
um on that note we shall take a break
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else